"Used to" means something done in the past but not anymore.
To "be used to" something is to be familiar with it.
He used to be homeless. Now, he's a businessman.
He used to be the president of the United States. Now, he's just an ordinary American.
The apartment used to be dark. Now, it's bright.
The city didn't use to be so horrible. It used to be nice.
Obama used to smile more. He's always frowning these days.
He used to be fat and overweight but now he's slim.
I've lived here ten years. I'm used to the traffic and noise.
I moved to Seattle five years ago, but I never got used to the rain.
I had to get used to driving on the left in England. People in the US drive on the right side.
I am used to having biscuits with my tea. It feels incomplete without them.